what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we got ourselves an Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania trailer John how are you
I'm very excited for this how are you sir
I'm doing good we got our citizen Kang shirts
real rejects exclusive at shopzer edition.com
koi chandro 117 days to land man very excited
oh wow you really counted it's Kang dude it's
Ken yeah King is coming it's time he's
coming all right guys let's get to it
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con how are you an Avenger
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing wow he's a real celebrity
helped that that's why we made this like a
satellite for deep space but Kawana wait wait a
minute you're sending a signal down to the quantum
realm goddamn right she is good job oh no too late
it's gonna be awesome such a
different tone from the other ones
oh that looks beautiful
God damn that looks beautiful dang
beneath ours
there's something I never
told you she slept with King
what you think
let's go
foreign
holy [__] so What's it gonna be
oh dude yep wow yeah trailer now before before
this played because I I know I had some people
uh message me like it's out it's out yeah I'm
aware I'm paying attention to checking for the
last four hours yeah there were people I know
that saw like you saw it at d23 like I heard
this trailer was actually different I hadn't
seen any of that because I didn't go to d23 I
heard this one is definitely different they had
sort of that like ethereal tone to it especially
with diving into the quantum realm from what I
heard from the previous ones that it felt like
much more harsh and harrowing when it came to King
and they didn't really capitalize too much on that
for their first debut trailer to go online but
for what we got here I thought it was actually
quite excellent I thought it was so beautiful to
behold and you know you get the teases of you know
uh Paul Rudd Scott Lang dealing with his ego trip
and the fact that he's on and I feel like I feel
like this is going to be a humbling experience for
him by the end as someone who thinks he's kind of
Unstoppable by this point and that he knows better
then he's gonna have to go up against someone like
Kang what I'm really excited for too is Janet's
story because it looks like we're going to be
unpacking her history with the quantum realm and
everything that she dealt with there because there
was obviously such a fear to going back there
other than the trauma being lost there sounds
like there was a real specific experience that
took place perhaps has some kind of understanding
of who King might possibly be and of course seeing
the culture and civilization with everyone there
I thought this was a beautiful trailer it was
it was really really beautiful Corey before you
go all deep diving here John what'd you think I
absolutely agree and I love the transition that
the tones go through because yeah you start
out in this sort of fun happy almost wacky
place with Scott and then you have the whole crew
together you got Cassie and hope and and the van
dynes and all that stuff and then you're going
on this beautiful looking Adventure across the
yellow brick road I even love the song choice
and the way they interpolate that and then it
gets more and more Sinister the more you know you
see these different entities and then ultimately
Kang and his forces is revealed I mean this looks
absolutely like something huge and important and
a cool way to make an Ant-Man movie feel like a
really huge and vital event and uh yeah like I
cannot wait for the imagination that I hope you
know is abundant in this movie as suggested by
this trailer and especially all the fun different
appearances we will get everyone loves Bill Murray
right now it's it's the time to have it time to
love Bill Murray right did we catch a motor back
to Howard the Duck Cameo alongside oh God based
on everything we've heard about that uh d23ts are
combined with this I'm so so so excited for this
movie Cory what'd you think I love first of all
that Kang's presence is so ominous no matter what
they're able to nail that just him descending and
also that they have the markings on his face that
mirror the markings on his mask I really like that
but what I'm most interested in is this does seem
to open up an entire world of possibility for the
greater MCU we've seen the strange esoteric and
bold and Doctor Strange and that's due to Magic we
haven't really seen it due to science and I
really think it's interesting that when you
look at time displacement you look at the size
of something and like like for example in Civil
War when when giant man appears and he grows
he seems to be moving slow because his sense
of reality and time is going to be different I'm
wondering how they're going to play around with
the time displacement of the quantum realm their
size versus Kang's perception of time how they're
going to play around with what time is in this
realm what they're going to play around with what
throwing Quantum realities at others offensively
and defensively how long have those people been in
that City there's so many things you can kind of
open up by opening up this Quantum realm in this
Quantum world and by adding science and Magic as
they're leading to his Iron Heart we're gonna see
Kang be theoretically the time side of things and
I do think we're going to start to see time and
Magic combine as we heard at d23 with the hood and
iron heart and those things so I'm really curious
what this realm connects to the others that that
feel like this look like and I do think it's one
of the most beautiful trailers I've seen I think
the scope of it and letting these artists have the
time to play in this world this looks like when
I first saw the Guardians of the Galaxy trailer
and I was just oh overwhelmed by the Kirby of it
all by the scope of the cosmic yeah so that plus
a character we already know as opposed to the
Guardians we had to meet the Guardians we had
to invest in their world and then their Universe
we already love Paul Rudd so we're just gonna get
to dive in to this world and experience what
this all sets up I could not have loved that
trailer more that's like a top Marvel trailer for
me Janet or Hank who's gonna die oh Hank's gonna
die I'm going I'm going Janet I think they both
might die I think I think son of a [__] what
if Ant-Man and the WASP represent those two this
time right they pass away because they're Ant-Man
and the WASP yeah and then they go yeah yeah well
I feel like one thing we're 100 getting every time
we see something with one of the younger players
that we're thinking joke Avengers Young Avengers
but Cassie already seems like she's already
upsetting Scott with her with her behaviors
and Antics and the path that she's going down so I
feel like we're getting a pretty direct setup for
her for her to be part of the young adventures
yeah I think when she leaves this it's stature
I think she might even be stature when they go
into the quantum realm I could see you know him
trying to identify with his daughter they're not
seeing eye to eye he makes her a costume or she
does it on her own as an actor Rebellion but I
also like that the opening of this trailer is him
not getting the respect he thinks he deserves and
being called Spider-Man but then but then at the
end the last line is Ant-Man so it mirrors like
oh I don't want him to know who I am they don't
know who I am there's an interesting like humbling
as well as like a bit of malice in knowing exactly
who he is I know I love that about it like it
seems like there's going to be a very specific
character Journey for him because I feel like with
even with the last Ant-Man movie it wasn't really
about Scott laying as much tends to be more about
the you know the van Don family yeah or the Pam
family yeah yeah yeah and and I feel like this is
going to be very much focused on laying you were
talking about time and and quantum mechanics
all those fun things I'm feeling like there's
gonna be some type of false Victory I feel by the
end where perhaps Our Heroes I like I don't think
Paul Rudd's gonna die I feel like they'll they'll
come out alive but they're gonna be traumatized by
the end and I feel like that's going to be setting
up something for perhaps Loki season two I think
this has to tie into Loki season two obviously
to the bigger picture with the Multiverse Saga
with Kang Dynasty and whatnot perhaps we might
see like alternate versions of other characters
in here and then we will probably see alternate
timelines like we're really gonna explore how
time works here because we had everything
with he who remains and there's been a lot
of theories going around about how you know the
TVA probably is within the quantum realm itself
and that's how he who remains was able to harness
control and during the multiversal wars and then
create his own version of a sacred timeline and
I think that's a big part of what we're going
to really digest and understand and I think this
will actually lead Segway in some way into Loki
season two specifically it's interesting this
kicks off this time alignment I'm wondering how
many things in this world deal with time because
you know phase four had so much multiversal stuff
obviously we're going to keep the Multiverse
stuff because it's all the Multiverse Saga but
this kicking off phase five this being an early
next year February release I'm really curious how
much timey why me quantum mechanics we do get
going forward plus I love the contrast here if
you hear the d23 footage is all like Avenger if
I killed you before and in here it just ends on
no Ant-Man I know exactly who you are yeah I mean
that's dichotomy between the uh Spider-Man like
the joke I also think like the darkness of going
from levity to Darkness is also very Ant-Man with
the tone we've established so far I'm excited to
see an Ant-Man movie that actually feels really
important and that is not disregarded because I
like the Ant-Man movies a lot and and I think that
they kind of get a weird rep as like they're just
kind of whatever well I think it's a tricky thing
is the character is in Canon scene as whatever
as a joke like it's a self-referential thing so
I feel like the the movie's got unfortunately
stuck with like oh it's just Ant-Man but like
that's supposed to be humorous and then it became
literal and Peyton Reed's a great director and
he loves the Marvel Universe like Peyton Reed is
one of us I don't know there's a lot of directors
that can give you a 20-minute dissertation on
each hero but he really looks like he he made
his Quantum realm he made what he's always
wanted to see in the comic books on screen
I was dazzled by it yeah I hope we actually get
a really explore that that group versus you know
just like a scene or two because I imagine that
a lot of that's linked to Janet's past and who
she was probably kicking I mean if you introduce a
Bill Murray character I imagine that's gonna he's
gonna be a Jeff Goldblum ask maybe he's another
one of the you know a bit larger beings Allah
The Gardener The Collector that he could be the
one in the quantum realm that watches over that
it'd be interesting if he was one of those beings
and then we've also got the entire civilization
of of you know aliens and and it looks like you
know Star Wars adjacent people that are trapped
in this realm cat or it's just or just funny
or is this building he's playing Bill Murray
he's just a cameo all right guys we'll leave
your thoughts down below be sure to subscribe
click that Bell tell us what you thought of the
trailer what are your theories for what's going
to take place who do you think's gonna die all
right we'll talk with you all soon thank you guys